and then they get really have you killed
a man what looks like my mother is doing
the walk of shame out of a frat house I
think my the google scared Jack last
night
never have I ever hooked up with someone
younger than you you have not how much
younger so you I married them never have
I ever done the walk of shame
you have horse who has come on Yugi the
walk machine I definitely have let's say
you ask I was young guys I think
sneaking out undercover is the walk of
shame right it's not like you regret
what happened it's more like 6:00 in the
morning
[Music]
let your exes think so no and then they
get really wet had you killed a man
what what did you say oh my god you have
hmm yeah but it was like three weeks
after the break-up
and you're like I can't do this and so
it was like a one or two of them I was
like moons and then it started to be
like I can't I can't hold the rest of
the shirt it's on fire I did like show
up at his house I'm like a torch never
have I ever gotten in a public place you
have yeah I was kidding though
we were playing football and got lost
and I thought oh I thought I'd got into
it I was like oh man look a little hot
you should put your head in the freezer
and he was just so upset it's like guys
like charged me telling my bad we got a
little fight yeah it's fighting words no
it is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you